On episode eight of Star Trek: Picard, titled
"Broken Pieces," we finally learn the dark
truth behind the synthetic attack on Mars
14 years before the start of the series, and
the crew of the La Sirena makes some surprising
discoveries.
Here are all the Easter eggs and references
you may have missed in "Broken Pieces."
We finally get confirmation in "Broken Pieces"
that Commodore Oh is what many have long suspected
-- a half-Romulan, half-Vulcan spy for the
Zhat Vash, who orchestrated the attack on
Mars.
"Where do we begin?"
"On the world the humans call Mars."
This isn't the first time Romulan spies who
are half-Vulcan have played a significant
role on Star Trek.
In The Next Generation season 4 episode "Data's
Day," Data is assigned to serve as an escort
for a "Vulcan" ambassador named T'Pel who
later is revealed to be a Romulan spy.
Given that "Broken Pieces" reveals that the
Zhat Vash's mission to prevent the evolution
of synthetics goes back hundreds of years,
it's safe to assume that the Zhat Vash was
wary of Data from the moment he was created.
Perhaps T'Pel wasn't just a Romulan spy, but
was actually an earlier generation of Zhat
Vash, gathering information on Starfleet's
only sentient synthetic.
After finding out in episode 7 of Star Trek:
Picard that Agnes Jurati had ingested a Romulan
tracking device, we learned in "Broken Pieces"
that it was made of viridium.
Despite never having appeared in its shiny
blue pill form before, viridium trackers have
actually been used in Star Trek since Star
Trek VI: The Undiscovered Country.
In that film, Spock places a viridium patch
on the uniform of Captain Kirk before Kirk
beams over to a Klingon ship.
Later, Spock uses the viridium patch to rescue
Kirk and McCoy from where they're being held
captive.
Star Trek: Picard has been doling out a new
Rios-based hologram on the La Sirena every
couple episodes, but by "Broken Pieces," it
seems as though we've finally met them all.
In total, there are five, each with a different
accent: an Emergency Medical Hologram, an
Emergency Navigational Hologram, an Emergency
Tactical Hologram, an Emergency Hospitality
Hologram, and one last emergency hologram,
whom we meet in episode 8.
"Are you Chris?"
"No, lassie, I'm the Emergency Engineering
Hologram.
But I go by Ian."
While the different accents and mannerisms
of the various holograms are an effective
way of differentiating between six different
characters that all look exactly the same,
Picard's inclusion of a Scottish engineer
who liberally tosses around the word "lassie"
feels far from coincidental.
On the original Star Trek series, the chief
engineer was Montgomery Scott, known amongst
the rest of the Enterprise crew as "Scotty."
While Ian, the EEH, appears to be his own
character, and not a carbon copy of Scotty,
his heavy accent and Scottish slang all seem
to be deliberate tips of the hat to the much-beloved
original character.
"Computer?
Ah.
Hello, computer."
When Rios acquired the La Sirena, he selected
the "self-scan" option, ostensibly by accident,
which led to the ship creating five identical
copies of Rios.
However, although the self-scan option seemingly
preserved all of Rios' memories, the captain
later went in and deleted a few of them in
order to cover up what happened on his previous
ship, the Ibn Majid.
In the process, Rios also made some careless
deletions of unrelated information.
"Ask me the proper temperature for making
Yridian tea, I no longer have any idea."
The Yridians were an alien species that first
appeared on The Next Generation, when a Yridian
named Jaglom Shrek lured Worf to a Romulan
prison camp by lying to him about his father
still being alive.
The ENH also says he's lost his knowledge
of Medusan astrogation techniques.
The Medusans are a non-corporeal race first
introduced in the original series In the episode,
the Enterprise finds itself flung into uncharted
space, and has to use Medusan astrogation
techniques to get back.
While Rios is sequestered in his quarters,
we get a good look at his bookshelves, which
is how we learn that the captain is an avid
reader of existentialist novels and philosophical
texts, including a Vulcan philosophy book,
Surak and Existentialism.
The Vulcan philosopher Surak was first introduced
in the original series' third season episode,
"The Savage Curtain," and is credited as being
the father of Vulcan civilization.
Of all the books on Rios' shelf, it is Surak's
teachings that are the most unique, since
he was a proponent of peace and his teachings
led to the Vulcans purging themselves of emotion,
while many of Rios' other books advocated
for the value of intense feeling.
Interestingly, it is Surak's teachings which
are off the shelf, suggesting that it is the
more controlled Vulcan philosophy, and not
the emotional Earth-originated teaching, which
Rios gravitates toward when he's feeling lost.
When Agnes finally comes face to face with
a sentient synthetic in Soji, she marvels
over the many human-like details in Soji's
construction, calling her a wonder and a work
of art.
Agnes goes on to explain that while Noonian
Soong considered himself an artist, he never
came close to creating anything like Soji.
This refers back to the fourth season Next
Generation episode "Brothers," in which Soong
likened his creation of Data to the sculptures
of Michelangelo, saying his process of creating
Data was similar, but harder.
"Wasn't quite that easy with you, Data.
But the need to do it, my need to do it, was
no different than Michelangelo's need."
When Agnes finally comes clean about why she
killed Bruce Maddox earlier in the season,
she explains that the Admonition was constructed
to warn future civilizations away from developing
synthetic life, so that they could avoid the
catastrophe that befell its creators once
they passed a "threshold" of advancement.
Rios immediately realizes what Agnes is talking
about, likening it to when Zefram Cochrane
invented warp drive.
In First Contact, it's explained that the
Vulcans had thought of humans as too primitive
to make contact, until they saw Cochrane's
warp drive test flight.
Then they changed their plans in order to
make contact.
It sounds as though there's another advanced
race out there that may be ignoring the Federation
for similar reasons for now, at least.
After gaining access to knowledge that had
previously been inaccessible to her, Soji
plans to use a transwarp conduit to get back
to her home world, which she hopes to reach
before the Romulans can get there.
Transwarp conduits were first mentioned in
the Next Generation episode "Descent, Part
I," in which Geordi explained how they worked.
"A ship, when entering the conduit, is immediately
accelerated to an extremely high warp velocity.
It's like falling into a fast moving river
and being swept away by the current."
However, the technology played a much more
significant role in Star Trek: Voyager, in
which the crew made several attempts to use
transwarp conduits to make their way back
to the Alpha Quadrant.
Although they were unsuccessful the first
couple times, they finally succeeded in the
series finale, "Endgame," when they used a
transwarp conduit to travel safely back to
Earth.
On the bridge of the La Sirena during a quiet
moment in "Broken Pieces," Picard reminisces
that it reminds him of an old memory.
"I remember standing the night watch as a
young ensign on the bridge of the Reliant."
While we've heard many tales of Picard's service
aboard the Stargazer throughout The Next Generation,
he's never talked much about his time on the
Reliant.
However, there was another, earlier version
of the U.S.S.
Reliant that played a much more significant
role in Star Trek history.
In Star Trek: The Wrath of Khan, the 23rd
century Reliant is commandeered by the villainous
Khan.
The Reliant ultimately wound up being destroyed
in the final showdown between Khan and the
Enterprise, but it appears that Starfleet
later commissioned another starship with the
same name.
Toward the end of "Broken Pieces," Picard
mentions that he once met Rios' former captain
when he served as first officer to one of
Picard's Starfleet Academy classmates: Captain
Marta Batanides.
Marta Batanides played a central role in the
Next Generation episode "Tapestry."
In the episode, Q brings Picard back to pivotal
moments in his past, allowing him to change
actions that he regrets.
Marta Batanides was one of those regrets;
she and Picard were close friends, but he
never acted on his romantic feelings for her.
Initially, he decided to change this, but
ultimately reversed that decision when he
realized that a romantic relationship would
lead to the end of their friendship.
Marta was also present for the bar fight with
the Nausicaans which ended with Picard getting
stabbed through the chest, leading to him
receiving his artificial heart.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.